do you think women only like double
standards when or complain about
complain about double standards when it
doesn't benefit us
go ahead
like um for example one more thing like
for example we don't see women
complaining about men not getting into
bars for free or having to not pay for
or have free drinks that's a double
standard if i speak about myself i feel
like i'm an anomaly yeah
yeah because for me personally i feel
like
like
i want to be as equal as a man is so if
you're in a club and you've seen 20
you've seen guys pay like whatever
entrance right and they say oh you don't
have to pay you're going to pay just
because you feel about equal standards
that's a cat i can't lie i'm not paying
you know what if i get it for free i'm
getting it for free but but if they're
telling me that i have to pay i'm not
going to be like oh get me in for free
do you know what i'm saying yeah i think
when it's in a in a setting like this
yeah i think agreed i think everyone is
i'm the anomaly type yeah but when it
comes to friday night and we're about to
walk to the club
i think and like
we're at the back of the line talking
about oh it's going to be
x amount to get in and they're giving it
this one oh yeah coming to the front
no girl like
girl really jasmine yo that's what
really drives me like we're talking
about
you choose like if a guy didn't open it
like do something like what's it called
what's that saying when something's dead
um romance not romance it's like
chivalry's dead
right what okay it's a society it should
be dead because everything's equal i'm a
king too you treat me like a kid yeah
right
type of vibes i pay for men
let the girls go yeah i've paid for a
date or two
uh yeah actually yeah
i
do i like to five to one ratio huh yeah
wait elaborate
he plays five times i play once wait um
wait where's someone alright so you said
you paid for it are you playing
but
it
saying no but i'm saying like i still
like to pay i make money and i think
this is the whole like balance of women
so he didn't like like you liked him for
being ugly and funny and then
then he figured out that right now
just say okay so they took you on a date
regardless of like why are you no i've
paid for dates four days you felt some
type of way though right you're like no
no no no i still put i'm with a
relationship like one day okay so then
would you pay for the second one would
you pay for the second one
what right after yeah
i think it's still fair like what i'm
spending all my time like say he's going
for some [ __ ] like that but you wanted
to see him you can play like one two or
three days
you have but like it's not a normal
thing like you wouldn't let that run all
the way of course but that's like what
what
yeah exactly and that sucks but i think
the point is like you still said five
dates to one it's not equal
no it's not but i'm still putting my
hand in my pocket where some women some
some women don't some women don't okay
but some women don't pay at all yeah
yeah somebody expects you to pay all the
time
i would actually go to a guy if i ask
you out on a date i'm paying 100
sounds good right now but i'm just
saying maybe that's the people you've
met so don't be deflecting that onto
this conversation thank you no it's not
deflecting that's just okay
it's not deflecting that's just like
that's what yeah it's not how it goes
because there are a lot of women out
there
on a date
quite a few actually i mean i'm actually
prior to relationships i've actually
paid for dates and i'm like
you can't have to quantify so there's a
lot so that's what i'm asking like quite
a few yeah like it's not what the your
opinions don't line up with like what
we're like talking about no it does no
it don't because you're on there it does
because i'm saying i'm not i can't
quantify how because i don't even
remember but i'm saying there's actually
quite a few dates i've actually paid for
like even prior to relationship within a
relationship
that's what i'm saying like like again
we're talking about okay you pulled out
your wallet here and there and that's
appreciated like a lot of girls you're
right like don't do that and i think but
but but it's still we're not asking for
equality here i know girls have been
mentioned you know
we're like on a date or something yeah
or like you're doing whatever it is i
like let's say you've done food drinks
like you're on the third date now or
something so like you don't pay first
date done paid second day
pay for the pay for the third day now
you now you move on to the next bar and
they're like
i'll get us a drink
what and then
and then next is your turn like they've
got some four pound drink out in tesco's
and it's like yo i've reached into my
pocket now that's a joke that's crazy
it's a joke thing yeah like for me but
like again like for me that five to one
like i'm seeing that is the same thing
like yeah if you're talking like that's
crazy like
crazy ratio like for saying like we pay
equal like yeah but i didn't say we play
equal no no but i'm saying you're like i
say i pay five one though is crazy like
that's not even that's not equal but i i
date a guy who doesn't want me to pay at
all and this is what the original
question about stereotypes no but he is
like he's like no i should be paying and
i'm i'm finding it hard because i'm such
an independent woman that i would always
pay
in my in in different ways right and so
every guy you met like you on a date
like you would like your mindset is
yeah four or five and i've paid for from
the rip that's what i'm saying like if a
guy's asked the girls going on a date
the number is way higher okay but i'm
just saying
also it's hard women aren't it's a
stereotype but when do women ask men out
on a date like i've gone up to a guy in
a bar and said you're really cute and
then i start talking to him i am
confident no not a lot of women are
confident my thing is the expectation
like say i take a gun on a date i would
just rather like yo even if you faking
it like i can't afford this date like
just put the put something out just
don't just sit there looking stupid no
like [ __ ] like you know what i mean just
like put it out there like and as a
jungler
i will pay for our pay
is that if you've asked them on that
date you want them to still pull out nah
like a first date yes yeah yes
regardless who has who on a
if you've not even done like a courtesy
lien
i will never speak to you again big
facts
no not for all i will never like the
girl like didn't like you always
never see them again
what if she doesn't offer but she's very
thankful no oh
what does that mean bro
no i'm capable of life like what were we
talking about well because sometimes
like the guy will just like take out his
card but i'm always like thank you so
much
don't even pay for it but that's what
i'm saying like like it's a test it's a
test for guys like yeah if the girl was
like didn't say nothing i'll never i
will never meet her again i'm sneakily
paid because i know he won't let me pay
so i need to go to the toilet and i'll
sneak a loop like we said
um what'd you call it the gesture like
from a guy's point of view but but we're
kind of going back back to the original
question like we have all these
we have a we have a [ __ ] march for women
you've never heard of that that much
like that's so so we complain about the
double standard we have a slot of like
the the body count thing right like
that's a double standard and women will
complain and they'll go
like like men have a higher body count
they don't get they don't get oh yeah
like yeah but women
yeah yeah and so
wow okay okay but i'm saying like like
so there are marches for that like we
have i don't know if you've heard of
this but there's like a [ __ ] march in
california
women will say oh let's own the word and
we'll complain for days about that but
we don't see women marching the streets
for men to pay equal or to you know get
into bars for free or anything else
themselves
we want equality but we only want
equality when it benefits us like where
where's the equality for why don't women
lined up to be plumbers
i feel like we are fighting like as a as
a as a woman yeah we fight for our own
stuff does that make sense so i feel
like if men want it like they should the
equal bar thing they should fight for it
themselves because you know what
especially we live in a world yeah where
men get a lot of more privileges like
okay cool yeah we get into bars and
stuff that's fair enough but there's a
lot of stuff where men are more superior
to women and that's one thing they get
paid more than a dollar no no no no no
just you and what like jobs like
especially
in terms of like jobs i feel like men
get ra men get a lot more respect
in sport okay cool men get a lot of more
like respect in terms of that a lot more
credit a lot more props a lot more
leeway advantages
how is that true when women have
specific grants like there are specific
grants only for women not given to men
on top of that on top of that and there
are quotas so they have to get a certain
amount of women in a job but when a
field is is female led there's no quota
for men so how so yeah so how is how is
there how
i feel like women are already fighting a
battle in itself so the money situation
itself like women get paid less to the
dollar to the to the man right but how
do you know how do you know that we're
paid less because we're women i mean
you're the stats ladies because you're
going out in the profession like if
you're going to be an engineer like
there's not a lot of female in the only
but even when it comes to sports right
the only sport that is paid the exact
same money though no but i'm saying oh
tennis but yeah
that's because respectfully i know i
love you men are better than women at
sports sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry you're probably you you
specific you're probably better than
most men but in general like most men in
the nba can dunk wnb can't
and they and they get paid more because
they make more money
like that like women's ncaa has been at
a loss for years they don't even make
money
why is that because because people don't
watch as much because it's just not as
entertaining who's i don't even keep who
runs the show who who's the top dog the
man because everybody know what you know
like no like if i like you i swear
i was like if i really want to watch a
women's game like i would watch a
women's game like that when it gets to
like
certain levels like finals semi-finals i
like i was here but like
this is like and i'm a sports person so
like imagine people like that aren't
like it's sad it's sad because listen if
i was a woman i would [ __ ] hate men
i'd be like the feminists like
slew them
but it's like it is like it is always
with like on an individual level what
we're going to do is the people
one second just that fact in itself what
you're saying you know i mean and that
is why there's those women groups
because of these situations it's so hard
for us to get jobs and then you add
race into it you add where you live
ethnicity all these things are so
difficult so yeah there are only women
clubs there are only women gyms oh no
there's not me because there's dirty old
men who wank in the corner
we got to stay at home and not work that
[ __ ] sounds awesome no but it's not
because
she's fighting though yeah sure is she
fighting with a squirrel no but but i'm
saying like like like even even the
women but that was only that came from
like the war days where the women had
jobs in the war and then the men came
home and then they took those women's
jobs so then they got put back in the
home of now you have to live well
like historically men had to fight in
war so how can we say we were oppressed
we never had to fight in wars no but i'm
saying
they're getting control
and then also and even and even let's
talk about the pay gap like the reason
that when men are paid more than women
is because they pick industries that
make more money
so like like if you go to the most
egalitarian countries in the world where
women have more choice
the the pay gap is bigger
because
men choose like professions with objects
or women's women choose professions with
people wait wait wait shout them out i
will later no but i'm asking like like
our automatic gut reaction is always
that like it's about male and female
but like how do you know it's not just
the industries we pick
no for sure industry like industry is a
big thing
no go ahead i've spoken my my part yeah
i agree with her a lot i can't lie um i
feel like there's just a lot of factors
like you can say okay cool like men get
to go work and the women get to stay at
home and it's all fun but it's not all
fun and games a lot of those women are
abused they're treated like crap like
that but why are they controlled but why
is that your immediate like like i just
don't understand why that's your
immediate gut reaction is to say like
they're at home because they're
controlled and they're abused and all
that stuff like i know what i'm asking
is that is that your your your view on
men it's just that you think the
majority of men are like abusing their
women no but i think a lot of those
women are unhappy and it comes from the
old school days like where they're
actually suppressed and they're kind of
taught they're brought into that
tradition and it just continues where a
lot of those women actually are unhappy
and they would like to speak out and
that's
like if your mom raised you like yo
don't chase [ __ ] from no man
like you would move completely different
cultures though
some families invite this some people
that's right that's where zania was like
that's where race comes into ethnicity a
lot of those things come like they're
big factors like we can all talk about
the positivity but there are other sides
like we're here to have a discussion on
all those different types of views so we
can't just say oh like yeah there's all
those women are happy but not all those
women are happy a lot of those who are
faking that happening
but how do you like why is that your
assumption how do you know we don't but
that is yeah but you also see it from
one
um perspective
in america so you only see one way so
you don't really see how the other
different ethnicities different cultures
have completely their women have to stay
at home that is you're saying that's
really cool but as women
we're starting to we want to be ceos we
want to be pushing where we're the equal
of men and this is what she's saying as
a young woman is saying like actually no
i would like to pay i would but do i
have the opportunities to make the same
money or do i have i've seen it even if
it's all these old schools but but i'm
saying like like if that's true like why
in the countries where women have more
choice than ever is the pay gap bigger
so you can you can make a list of
countries right where women are the most
depressed and the least depressed and
the pay gap grows when women have more
choice
because of the industries they pick but
a lot of men so i'm not even talking
about other factors i'm just talking
about like male and female go ahead so a
lot of men do run those industries
though that determine those pays like a
lot of men even that they're very biased
in terms of like even internal
promotions and stuff within companies
but they can't change a pay grade like
of like yo you're a man
but i'm saying to to offset that we have
quotas so there are like i worked in
copier sales for two years that's a very
male dominated industry it's [ __ ] it's
awful
oh my god
and they couldn't get women to stay
because it was terrible like it's a like
those those jobs are working 80 90 hours
a week my dad worked 80 hours a week my
whole life
i do you want i don't want to work 80
hours a week i don't know many girls
that do there's a lot of women that
actually are out there like even in a
lot of countries like they're working a
lot they're working like two free jobs
just to keep it yeah but i'm saying but
i'm saying if that's true then why in
the countries where they have the most
choice to do that do less women
like like y'all we're all wealthy like
so then what's the difference so i'm
saying like like you go to the countries
where women have more choice and
opportunity to do those things and they
choose not to why if women want to
i think it's just a lot to do with like
history as well though like you're stuck
in a phase so maybe women i i'm not
saying women don't make there's a lot of
women that make stuff harder for
themselves like we do all have a choice
but there's a lot of circumstances that
dictate that like we can even go back i
don't know this is relevant but it
actually makes sense to me like the
whole molly may like we all have 24
hours in a day like we actually don't
have the same 24 hours in a day like
everyone's circumstance is actually
different everyone says
there's so many factors that come into
that like like culture like everything
like it's just the opportunities don't
actually get given like as much as you
think they do that's a race thing it's
not like a gender thing for sure like
it's not just it's not just race though
like there's a lot of caucasian women
that face those issues
disability like there's a lot of like
other other factors but i'm saying like
just pure gender like
but then if you're like you would never
you wouldn't reject a job for like a
woman
over a man because you saw the name if
they had the same skills like
well and the other question is like why
aren't we rallying like we'll talk about
ceo and power positions but why aren't
we talking about women not wanting to be
things like garbage collectors plumbers
like all the hard jobs in the in the
military
like it's always like like that's what
i'm saying we only kind of
there's a lot of women in the military
but they get treated like absolute [ __ ]
they don't get paid you know women
though you don't i don't know any man
i don't know any women plumbers but i
know a navy person and he they
disrespect women like nothing they treat
them like [ __ ] and he's a high-ranking
person no that's not i don't know
and so it's hard to be this but then
there's also it's like okay there's not
men beauticians like there's this job
there's just gender jobs that just like
uh we're trying to break off why can't
there be a woman plumber why can't there
be a man who does my eyelashes
there's not enough man being like yo i
want to do eyelashes so then it's like
right there and stereotypes
but this is why like i'm going back to
the same question where it's like we're
complaining about inequality when it
doesn't like benefit us
or when it we complain about inequality
but only like we only complain about the
ones that don't benefit us like we don't
we don't rally the same way we're always
intrigued to like hear this like really
intruder like because obviously you like
for women you're fighting for like
yourself like
and i like i said i'll be the same way
if i was a woman i would hate me
but i'm saying like for the ones that
benefit you like but are you rallying
are you rallying because you're paying
to get into clubs not everyone's
rallying yo not every girl's right out
here rallying like nobody
i'm saying you no are you i don't mind
them coming together like yo i'm sick of
paying a hundred pounds
it's not about running it's about
sharing your opinion like oh yo these
are in for free like whatever that you
can't say that about guys you can't like
you know what i mean like that's it
you're contradicting yourself there
because she did she just asked you a
question and said but are you valiant
i'm not gonna rally because
where women don't get the rights
but i'm saying
there's a guy that probably went to that
rally that is just going because his
wife's there
like it's not like they care like it's
just like if it affects you then you
would you would have a reason like for
women's rights like it's very different
because if it affects you then managing
thrown off like their phone like
object like you know i mean in the
background like they're going to be like
just think stereotypes you're right
every each gender picks which one
affects them which one they want to care
about which i i mean i've had
relationships where it's really
affecting me i'm like why can you do
this and i can't do this like and i
think maybe in sporting world also like
we're in a very oh i think most women
but we're in a very man like driven in
yeah dominated sports so now though
shout outs
and it is frustrating i'm sure it's
frustrating to you too like i wish women
were paid more in sports it's ass like i
mean you probably actually make decent i
know people don't even like watching
women's sport i don't believe in it like
yeah i've had like a top like top top
guy say to me yeah we just come for the
drinks and the party for the women like
you lot are just our social club big boy
i'm talking like
top top top
level and just said to me not our
country but just said like yeah i just
come for the bands like i just come to
see the women play and have a drink with
my mates like we don't respect it and if
the top men are talking like that how do
you think it then affects how do you
think it trickles down
you don't think there's a talent
difference in men and women in like like
basketball
okay who's the better team london lions
women or men
you know if we played you we're better
yeah
you think we praise you
but if you if you're i think right when
it comes if you're not
if
men and women in like sports personally
basketball because i'm a basketball
player myself and i love watching
basketball i feel like men play with
pride and women play as a team that's
what i think okay so if you're not
allowed if you're not allowed to dunk
if you're not
listen listen listen listen if you're
not allowed to dunk
and we pl we should do this
everybody on that day let's i think we
should do it you know i think we should
do it
i think we should do it
dude if you're not generally thinking
like yo i could beat them in a minute no
one is going on julian like no one will
no no no no you really think you'd be
our team like well not in a full game
what fight like a minute like no no no
like not to eleven like
jordan
right
every single time but even though that's
what you're saying like can you guys
[Music]
but even even in this game you're
proposing you still have to put a
handicap on them so they don't beat you
like you still have to say you can't die
okay you can dunk like but i'm saying i
love it it'll be quite fun
i would like to it'll be fun everyone
i'm live streaming on my channel
play for my heart do you remember that
basketball yeah
11-0 i feel like men's physiology is a
bit different for to women so they could
last a bit long like it's something that
i've had to grow up and like like me
when i was younger i'm like i'm better
than guys what are you talking about but
obviously you had to grow up realizing
that yeah they're stronger than me
they're faster than me they have a
sec i don't know what it's called but
they can last longer in a game
more than women but
but i feel like when it comes to
entertainment entertainment wise they
can be better but if personally as a
basketball player i'd rather watch a
woman's game but but like you realize
like the results kind of speak for
themselves by who who views what for
example we have like athleticism all
that kind of stuff it's nice
it's not it's not like a fun reality i
don't enjoy this like i wish i wish i
could make more money playing volleyball
it just is what it is i can't i can't
not see what it is i wish
[Music]
i think we should make it